oh that's a question for me I have no
idea I'll Korea no you out of ten I
don't know I feel like you should answer
that for me I look very Korean I can
people telling those physical wise
you're you're like eight oh say eight or
ten okay hurry and personality-wise I
think you're why bye
Evan I think just look wise like you
said physical I think you look more
American and Korean but personality-wise
six six yeah we both fluently speak
Korean
we both speak Korean in our households I
think we're fairly riding between the
Western culture and the Korean culture
we both do now we're break up in Korea I
noticed a lot of guys actually do a
makeup on a daily basis
looking pretty is it's kind of like a
trend cosmetics for men is so developed
you know we have like something called
pact so it's like your hands get messy
they don't want that so like BB cream
but in like a little circular tube and
you just have to open up and they have a
mirror they have that cushion thing
interesting yeah I did not know that and
they have that specific line for men
Oh in terms of why Korean Graduate
makeup I think it's more of like a
cultural Beauty standard is a little
different from here guys tend to look
more prettier especially in South Korea
like if you look better if you're
prettier you're socially more acceptable
like that's just how it is
it's messed up but this is how it is
whatever boosts your confidence I know
but like it's your life go ahead I mean
I yeah do it you do you it's a mandatory
thing for like two years around two
years even if you live in America and
you are a Korean citizen you have to go
back serve and then come back that only
applies if you don't have permanent
residency if you're a permanent resident
or you're I'm reconsider then you have
to enlist it kind of became a culture
thing where if you don't go and if you
live in Korea Korean men kind of just
look down on you
I like cash I like cash that's a gift
expression I don't know I think cash
okay so I'm a nonsmoker I've never
smoked cigarettes in my life I am a
heavy smoker I mean I'm trying to cut
down that was one of my resolutions but
I completely failed I was good for like
two days I just had cigarettes around
the house I have an older brother and my
and my dad and my brother both used to
smoke I think I just started as a
curiosity boys and girls ladies and
gentlemen do not smoke nowadays in Korea
it's really hard to smoke out in the
street because there's designated spots
only for smoking if you go outside of
the boundary and someone catches you
that you have to pay a fee I think Korea
is trying to become more free like
lifestyle yeah right so that's good
feeling Koreans they only go to bars for
our nightlife is such a big thing in
Korea difference between Korean bars and
American Voices American bars is uh
people stand walk around you know what I
mean right
but Korean bars it's like a table
service so you sit and like just talk
for our bars or cafes at coffee shops
cafes and they just like sit there and
talk yeah that's how we hang out I wear
a mask sometimes I wear masks would have
to travel I don't want to get sick it's
just to protect myself on airplanes to
airplane is like the place that you get
sick everybody to wear masks in your
honor airplane mask it's like part of
fashion too interesting huh yeah it's
part of a fashion it's like covering
your mouth is a point back it's a cars
from kpop I feel like just keep idols
when they don't wear makeup and they're
going somewhere they have masks to like
hide their identity traditional Korean
way of saying hello even if your same
age you would bow if it's your first
time yeah yeah if it's your first time
and you don't know that person it's a
completely stranger you bow even it's
still younger you bow if I saw Evan for
the first time for the show yeah oh yeah
about and then once we get to know each
other you have to pay more it but you do
bow to older people definitely it's like
chewy I respect definitely you go with
your group of friends you go to a
drinking place sit down so I tell the
waiter to like bring us
so to that table full of give them sign
like then they'll of course look at you
drink together yeah
should we go what do you want to come
like girls ooh say yes and they say no
to they're like oh we're okay we're just
here to chill they just they're just
yeah they're there they're showing you
that they really have an interest in
yeah they're just trying to be friends
they just wanna get to know you these
are great questions I mean thank you
guys for something that's in Google
right okay yeah thank you google you
googled it
we answered for you hopefully we
answered a couple you have them pretty
accurately accurately
[Music]